Denise Mitchell
Deputy James Brown
Deputy Mary Butler
Deputy Thomas Byrne
Deputy Jackie kahal
Deputy Dara caleri
Deputy Jack Chambers
Deputy Nile Collins
Deputy Barry Cowan
Deputy Carl Crowe
Deputy Karma Devlin
Deputy Stephen Donnelly
Deputy Joe Flaherty
Deputy Sean Fleming
Deputy Nora Norma Foley
Deputy Sean Holly
Deputy John lahart
Deputy James Lawless
Deputy Michal Martin
Deputy Paul McAuliffe
Deputy Charlie mcconologue
Deputy Michael McGrath
Deputy John McGinnis
Deputy Andreas Moynihan
Deputy Michael Moynahan
Deputy Jennifer mernan O'Connor
Deputy Amy O'Keefe
Deputy Tara O'Brien
Deputy Jim o'callaghan
Deputy James O'Connor
Deputy Willie OD
D Deputy Christopher O'Sullivan
Deputy Park Sullivan
Deputy Ann rabbit
Deputy Brandon Smith
Deputy Neve Smith
Deputy Robert Troy
Deputy Colin Brophy
Deputy Richard Bruton
Deputy Colin Burke
Deputy Peter Burke
Deputy Karen Cannon
Deputy Joe Carey
Deputy Jennifer Carroll McNeil
Deputy Simon covney
Deputy Michael Creed
Deputy Alan Dillon
Deputy Pascal Donahue
Deputy Berner Durkin
Deputy Damian English
Deputy Alan Farrell
Deputy Frankie Fein
Deputy Charles Flanagan
Deputy Brendan Griffin
Deputy Simon Harris
Deputy Martin Hayden
Deputy Emer Higgins
Deputy Heather Humphries
Deputy Paul Kyo
Deputy Joseph Madigan
Deputy Helen mcentee
Deputy Joe McHugh
Deputy Hildegard nachton
Deputy Kieran O'Donnell
Deputy Patrick O'Donovan
Deputy Ferguson doubt
Deputy John Paul Phelan
Deputy Neil Richmond
Deputy Michael Ray
Deputy David Stanton
Deputy Leo varadker
Deputy Patrick Costello
Deputy Francis Noel Duffy
Deputy NASA hurrigan
Deputy Brian leadden
Deputy Catherine Martin
Deputy Stephen Matthews
Deputy Malcolm Noonan
Deputy Marco classic
Deputy Joe O'Brien
Deputy Roger O'Gorman
Deputy Ayman Ryan
Deputy ocean Smith
Deputy Chris Andrews
Deputy John Brady
Deputy Martin Brown
Deputy Pat Buckley
Deputy McCarthy
Deputy Circa Clark
Deputy Rose Conway Walsh
Deputy Raider Cronin
Deputy Sean Crowe
Deputy David cullinan
Deputy Parr Daly
Deputy Pierce Doherty
Deputy Paul Donnelly
Deputy Desi Ellis
Deputy morade Farrell
Deputy Kathleen function
Deputy Thomas gold
Deputy Charlie quirk
Deputy Martin Kenny
Deputy Claire Curran
Deputy Park McLaughlin
Deputy Mary Lou McDonald
Deputy Denise Mitchell
Deputy Imelda monster
Deputy Johnny maithon
Deputy Owen O'Brien
Deputy Donahue lira
Deputy roria Morocco
Deputy Angus osnodig
Deputy Louise O'Reilly
Deputy Taron O'Rourke
Deputy Mars quinlivan
Deputy Patricia Ryan
Deputy Brian Stanley
Deputy Pauline Tully
Deputy Mark Ward
Deputy Ivana
Deputy Brandon Howland
Deputy Alan Kelly
Deputy Chad Nash
on
Deputy Sean Sherlock
Deputy Duncan Smith
Deputy Holly Kearns
Deputy Gary Gannon
Deputy Catherine Murphy
Deputy Keno Callahan
deputy roshin shortall
Deputy Jennifer Whitmore
Deputy Mick Barry
Deputy Richard Boyd Barris
Deputy Gino Kenny
Deputy Paul Murphy
Deputy breed Smith
Deputy Carl Berry
Deputy Sean Connie
Deputy Peter Fitzpatrick
Deputy Noel grealish
Deputy Michael Lowery
Deputy Verona Murphy
Deputy Dennis knockton
Deputy Matt Shanahan
Deputy Potter tobain
Deputy Michael Collins
Deputy Danny Healy Ray
Deputy Michael Healey Ray
Deputy Marty McGrath
definitely Carol Nolan
Deputy Richard O'Donoghue
Deputy Joan Collins
Deputy Michael fitzmaris
Deputy Marion Harkin
Deputy Michael McNamara
Deputy Thomas Pringle
Deputy mark mcshary
Deputy Violet Ann Wynn
leave
foreign
thank you
foreign
thank you
thank you
foreign
the tellers please come forward
tellers most of the hell
foreign
foreign
that all Air nominates Deputy Lee of
Radka for appointment by the president
to be Tisha Tara result
yes 87 Neil shuskado no 62 Richard
foreign
[Applause]
foreign
foreign ish
Eric Dane of Karu lenardir the cowenced
con docus
a will again
Alaskan Carla I'm very proud of the
states that was created 100 years ago
under most extreme pressure
throughout difficult crises and
challenges our democracy endured and
survived and prospered
we won the ultimate Freedom that all
nations desire and develop to as Michael
Collins predicted
and we owe a debt to men and women of
all political parties and all traditions
a crucial year in the history of our
state was 1932.
because that's when the wishes of the
people were respected the Democratic
principle was put ahead of all others
and there was a peaceful transfer of
power
the coming together of finagle Athena
fall in a shared government of the green
party in 2020 was less significant but
was nonetheless another important moment
in our history
I'm asking Carla I want to take this
opportunity to commend Neil Martin on
the leadership that he showed as tishook
for putting the country before politics
and for providing reassurance and hope
during difficult times
in 2020 the incoming teacher was unable
to have his wife and family with them at
the convention center
as he received the greatest honor of his
life
that too was leadership and I'm really
glad that they're with us today
during the pandemic we all saw the best
of each other and it meant that the new
Coalition was born in a spirit of
togetherness and Hope
and I intend that Spirit to continue as
we Implement with our partners in the
green party the agreed program for
government
I'd also like to thank my family friends
and staff
thank you for your work your love and
your support
when we enter public life we choose that
path our loved ones do not
and I want you to know that my work as
t-shirt was driven by your example and I
intend to honor your confidence in me
I also want to thank in particular my
constituents in Dublin West for giving
me the opportunity to serve as a TD and
for electing me on four occasions
all of us whether we're ministers our
leaders or opposition spokespeople know
that our mandate ultimately derives from
the people who vote for us on Election
Day and for that I remain eternally
grateful
I also want to thank all the deputies
who supported my nomination from Phoenix
Fall the green party and Independence
when I became t-shock in June 2017 so
much of the focus was on my election and
what it represented and symbolized
that was understandable at the time
but I think we should focus on where our
country is now and what needs to be done
as we prepare for our next Century of
statehood
our history of the last 100 years has
been about winning the additional
freedoms that were denied to us are
which we are unable to imagine at the
time
becoming a republic
becoming a place where you're not
limited by your gender religion race
background or sexual orientation
becoming a country where you're free to
be yourself
so what are the challenges for the next
hundred years
we have many and some of them we need to
fix now
otherwise we will be betraying the
current generation and the generation to
come after us
I'm thinking particularly of Housing and
how we have to go all out to turn the
corner on Rising homelessness and
falling home ownership
we need to accelerate our plan housing
for all making home ownership a reality
for the many again
I'm thinking of how we need to tame
inflation and bring the cost of living
under control especially when it comes
to the cost of energy Child Care
education rent and health care
I'm thinking about climate and
biodiversity the challenges facing our
planet
and the need to set ourselves the
ambition of becoming energy independent
and develop the ideas and systems and
mechanisms to make sure that happens
I believe we can harness our massive
untapped renewable natural resources
providing greater energy security stable
prices more jobs and Regional
development
I'm also thinking as we all are about
the unprovoked war that has brought debt
and Devastation to Ukraine
and today I reaffirm our commitment to
stand with our fellow Europeans in this
harsh winter and to help them in every
way we possibly can
I'm thinking of the Defense Forces the
men and women who put the safety of
others above their own and in particular
private Sean Rooney
we offer our condolences to his fiance
his family and his friends and our
thoughts and prayers are also a trooper
Shane Carney we wish him a speedy
recovery
I'm thinking of the Good Friday
agreement of nearly 25 years ago
fundamental elements of that agreement
the assembly and the executive are still
suspended
account Corolla or rather Alaskan
Corolla dreams of a better future are
not built on stalemate and stages quo
and I want to work with all parties in
this house and in Northern Ireland as
well as the British government and our
partners in the European Union to make
progress on the protocol and to restore
the institutions of the agreement
I'm also thinking of the most vulnerable
in our society and especially children
we need to improve access to therapies
provide better special needs education
and do more for those who need it the
most
we also need to do more about child
poverty and disadvantage
we know that poverty restricts a child's
opportunity and casts a long Shadow over
their lives
the number of children experiencing
consistent poverty has fallen by forty
five thousand we are making progress but
it still means that too many children
are missing out on the everyday
opportunities they deserve
I'll speak more about these matters
later on
Alaska quarter Ireland has never been a
failed State and it is grotesque and
dishonest to claim that we are our ever
were
but we are failing some of our citizens
and it's essential to our success as a
country that we spend the next two years
doing all we can to put this right
in eight days time most homes around the
country will celebrate Christmas with
presents and good cheer
most but not all
for some families for some children
Christmas is a time of fear and
uncertainty and a time of great
unhappiness
the greatest resource of any country is
its people
so let's try to make sure that all our
people have a fair chance starting with
our youngest they're held continuing
with their education staying with our
young people until they're able to
create the future they want providing
with them with the stepping stones to
their ultimate freedom
our ambition is to make Ireland the best
country in Europe in which to be a child
as t-shirt my mission will be to build
on the achievement of a hundred years
ago
and to work on what needs to be done for
this generation and the next
providing hope and housing economic
economic opportunities and a fair start
for all
and so I accept this nomination by the
doll
with humility and resolve
with a burning desire to make good the
promise of a hundred years ago and
provide New Hope and new opportunities
for all of our citizens gurmeelagev
[Applause]
and they should talk and see erfion
regular model
thank you